hey guys it's justine and oh my goodness
the apple iphone 14 rumors are heating
up and now here we are on mac rumors and
it's saying that apple is planning to
hold the iphone 14 event on september
7th so i guess mark your calendars most
of the time a lot of these rumor sites
they're pretty accurate and pretty true
so i am definitely putting in my
calendar september 7th i haven't really
been looking at the iphone 14 rumors and
i just kind of glanced to take a little
peek to see what people are saying and
see what everyone thinks is going to be
released because like it's almost time
like september 7th is going to be here
before we know it and even if the event
isn't september 7th september is iphone
season and i'm so here for it you all
know that so let's take a quick look and
see what some of the rumors are
for the 2022 iphone lineup so this is
sad for anybody who was an iphone mini
fan that said that they're going to be
eliminating the 5.4 inch mini phone as
it turned out to be unpopular with
customers but here's the thing how
unpopular it may have been is probably
equally as popular as it is with the
people who are super into the iphone
midi so i don't know i still feel like
there's a market for it so i guess if
you do want the mini you're gonna have
to stick with the iphone 13 because it
looks like the sizing though for the
flagships they're expecting to see a 6.1
inch iphone 14 a 6.1 inch iphone 14 pro
6.7 inch iphone 14 max and a 6.7 inch 14
pro max yeah okay let's just keep going
let's keep scrolling no notch and new
face id hardware design pro only rather
than just a single hole punch cut out
apples working on a design that will
incorporate both a pill shaped cutout
and a circular cutout the circular
cutout will likely house the face id dot
projector and the pill shaped cutout
will work
to include the front camera face id
infrared camera and possibly other
components interesting so something that
samsung has been doing a really great
job of is their under display camera i
think they did an incredible job on the
samsung galaxy z fold yes fold flip fold
i keep getting them confused even though
i know in my mind one folds and one
flips i i'm trying the fold has a really
great under display camera and it
doesn't seem like that is something that
apple is doing this year although it
says apple may be planning to put some
of the face id hardware under the
phone's display which will cut down on
the size of the cutouts that are needed
and we'll leave more available screen
space on the front of the device pro
motion display there were early iphone
14 rumors suggesting that all four
iphone 14 models
would offer promotion
but it looks like that's not going to
happen okay well i guess we'll move on
now that our dreams have been crushed
likely to restrict promotion to the 14
pro models only okay a move that may
suggest that there's a lack of
availability of the necessary displays
which also
could be a possibility the body design
oh yes let's
let's see it the iphone 14 models are
expected to look like the iphone 13
models with the same flat edge design i
feel like i'm kind of like ready for a
change i'm ready for something new but
here's the thing like this version of
the iphone it's pretty great so it's
like how much do you change how much do
you
try to iterate on something that is
already so good just for the sake of
trying to do something different than
the previous version i don't know it's
pretty great i think this phone looks
incredible here this says a photo that
allegedly depicts molds of apple's
upcoming iphone 14 surfaced back in
april so this is giving us kind of a
clear view of the sizing which looks
very very similar to
to this one so here's a set of cases the
1414 pro 14 plus
14 pro max so here's some color options
the purple is is that purple purple
shade that has a unique finish that
shifts tone based on lighting conditions
i clearly am into the color purple also
the bora color on the new samsung galaxy
z flip freaking beautiful i mean these
devices look almost identical i mean i
know these are renders but that looks
just like the iphone 13. titanium oh
interesting apple's upcoming iphone 14
models are expected to come with a
high-end titanium alloy according to
investors apple has used titanium for
the apple watch but this would mark the
first time that the material has been
used for an iphone i've actually not
purchased the titanium apple watch
before i've always got either the steel
or the ceramic the ceramic apple watch
still to this date is my absolute
favorite and i
kind of hope and wish that they bring it
back honestly if there was a ceramic
iphone i probably would also be very
into that so
they did a ceramic apple watch and a
ceramic iphone oh my gosh i would
probably pass out starting in 2022
high-end iphone models are likely to
adopt a vapor chamber thermal system
let's hear it for the vapor chamber
thermal system which apple is said to be
aggressively testing i'm sure many of
you guys have experienced this but
trying to do something on your phone in
a hot sunny day the screen starts to dim
it is absolutely the most frustrating
infuriating thing ever because i end up
not even being able to see the screen i
don't care if my battery dies quicker i
need this screen to be brighter and i
need my phone to not overheat so i'm
definitely very interested to see how
this thermal system holds up on the new
iphones lightning port is this going to
be the time are we here are we finally
going to get rid of lightning they are
saying that from the dummy models that
looks like it's going to be a lightning
port usb-c is a little bit larger so i
guess you would kind of be able to tell
so i'm still holding out i think that
this is the year we're gonna get usbc
and if it isn't that's fine i love
setting my expectations high and then
getting them crushed that's why i don't
i normally set them super low and then
anything that happens is always so much
cooler so this is a dummy model right
here of the iphone 14
and this is the iphone 13 pro blue
so yeah looks very similar but again how
do you mess with perfection here are
some front glass panels so this is
showing that
notchless design here on the iphone 14
pro max it looks like the 14 max and the
regular 14 still have the notch pros
notch is gone camera technology let's
talk about it
all of the 2022 iphones i also can't
believe it's 20 22. i wrote 20 21 the
other day and i just had to stop and i
couldn't believe it i was like we're in
2022 baby we're set to see improvements
with the ultra wide camera the iphone 14
pro models will see significant
improvements to the wide angle and
updates to the telephoto lens
it's believed that we could get a 48
megapixel wide camera yeah that would be
a huge upgrade because it's currently 12
and 8k video recording capabilities i do
feel like
8k
shooting on phones is kind of gimmicky
because you're not really getting the
full capacity of this footage yes i'm
excited about that happening but also
for
everyday consumers
it's going to be a burden you're going
to be filling up the storage on your
phone which is already they're talking
about needing to add a two terabyte
option which you're going to have to
especially if you are shooting this ak
content what is great is now with 5g and
finally kind of getting to a place where
it is starting to be more places you'll
be able to start storing this stuff in
the cloud and to be able to upload and
download as needed so it won't have to
be actually stored on device i think
that's really the only way that this is
going to make sense i mean most people
like my parents i don't think you're
gonna be recording ak content i mean
they might be because they're my parents
but like most people's parents or
grandparents are not gonna be recording
8k
videos of whatever it is that they're
filming ak video recording feature will
allow iphone recorded videos displayed
on an 8k display or tv to provide a
better user experience and that the
resolution will allow the iphone to
create videos and images more suitable
for augmented and mixed reality devices
like ar and vr headsets that apple has
in development oh
this is cool that is actually a good
point i think the thing that i love so
much about the iphone and sort of being
in the apple ecosystem is the future of
ar with their lidar and like all of the
things that they've been doing with ar
kit i'm super
super excited to kind of see the route
that they take with ar because they've
been kind of implementing this into the
dev kits and kind of getting people
ready and kind of getting developers to
sort of think a little bit differently
and to think larger like what can you
guys actually do with this so
hmm okay all right yep as for the front
camera technology all of the iphone 14
models coming this year are expected to
feature an upgraded front lens with a
wider f 1.9 aperture and auto focus
capabilities a wider aperture would
allow for more light to pass through the
lens to reach the sensor for sharper
crisper photos and improved depth of
field so keeping in mind that people are
using these things for
a lot more than selfies i think is
really important people are taking
classes like we're still in the age of
not everyone is going back to work not
everyone is going back to school so many
things are now digital and happening
from home or from remote places that
this is like your key to the outside
world i mean i basically
could
function perfectly fine if i lost
everything if i didn't have a computer
if i didn't have anything like i could
continue making youtube videos i could
do everything from this phone
and that is so empowering the a16 chip
new iterations of the iphone typically
come with an updated a series chip but
apple might deviate oh
so only the iphone 14 pro models will
get a new and faster a16 chip says the
standard iphone 14 models will continue
to use the same i-15 bionic that's in
the iphone 13 models i mean i think it
kind of makes sense because honestly if
you can still push the boundaries of
this a15 and
not need to go to the a16 i don't know
i'm not sure i don't know how i feel
about that like i'm trying to think it's
okay is it okay i don't know i don't
think i'm gonna actually know until i
actually see the device and see how it
works see how it operates is this going
to cut down costs for people will this
get new devices in the hands of more
people because they're able to cut down
costs and not use the newest latest
fastest chip i don't know
they're saying here though that these
new devices even if they are using the
a15 bionic chip will still get an
overall performance boost thanks to
updated cellular modem a new internal
design and other updates which could see
it offering faster performance which
totally makes sense if you're kind of
reconfiguring everything in here and if
you are getting i think they said that
the pros would be the only one that has
the new thermal so that would actually
make sense because you're not going to
need the new thermals if you're still
using the a15 pioneer chip so yeah that
makes sense understand i see i see you
now both the iphone 14 and 14 pro models
will feature six gigs of ram which is
the same amount available 13 pro models
okay all right car crash detection
they're working on a car crash detection
feature for the iphone and the apple
watch which could come out in 2022 it
will use sensors like the accelerometer
to detect car accidents when they occur
by measuring a spike in gravitational
force i think that's actually pretty
incredible because a lot of times you
know you're not able to get to your
device if something traumatic like this
happens and i think that's what i've
loved so much about the apple watch is
their fall detect and all of those kinds
of things that can help people when
they're not able to help themselves so
i'm really excited about that snapdragon
x65
modem this is the world's first 10
gigabit 5g modem and antenna system for
smartphones satellite connectivity you
have my attention the qualcomm
snapdragon x65 enables some satellite
connectivity features and alongside the
modem apple plans to implement
satellite-based emergency features that
will let users send texts in emergency
situations and report major emergencies
in areas where there is no cellular
coverage i've talked about this before i
used to have one of the garmin
emergency cellular
little devices i don't think what
they're called but i love this thing and
i haven't been hiking as much in remote
places so i have disconnected my service
i would take this everywhere i would
take it on hikes i would take it
traveling because just knowing that i
had this backup device in case this
little guy did not have cell reception
so that will be really great if i'm able
to do that on my iphone and even if this
is an added extra service or a charge
that would be definitely worth it
especially if you do things like remote
hiking or go places where there is no
cell reception such a great idea wi-fi
6e
2 terabyte storage no physical sim slot
iphone 14 pricing so it's expected to be
starting at price at 7.99 which is the
same starting price for the f-13 they
don't have plans to increase the cost of
the entry-level smartphone that's good
that's nice oh boy wow we future iphone
rumors oh my goodness like we haven't
even got through the iphone 14 and we're
already talking about like future
iphones 2023 iphones are expected to
feature the same
we'll have a dual cut okay so we're
still talking about this usbc they're
saying that in 2023 apple will finally
do usbc i'm still holding out for this
year
still holding out in-house modem chips
would make sense that apple would
probably go this route since they are
doing that with their apple silicon so
it would make sense that like hey if we
can do this why can't we do this your
apple you can literally do anything you
want you can do it all you can have it
all
your empire periscope lens if a
periscope telephoto lens is not ready to
debut in 2022 it could be introduced in
the 2023 models under display face id
they're saying that the components like
the infrared camera will not be moved
under the display until 2023 or 2024
foldable phone yeah that's not gonna
happen i mean i would literally
i i don't even know what i would do if
apple announced a folding phone in the
upcoming weeks i don't even know i don't
know i would be so absolutely shook that
i probably yeah
i i don't even know i feel like i would
shoot up out of my seat so quickly that
you would think that there was a spacex
rocket that took off from my home
because that's how incredibly shook i
would be potentially introduced i don't
know i don't i don't think i don't think
that happened of course they're gonna
start it's apple they're working on so
many secret things we will never know we
will never know
but i'm pretty sure it's safe to say
that they're definitely working on
something foldable let's pop over to
nine to five mac see if they have any
other photos that we can take a look at
that looks beautiful no notch but oh
yeah look at that i love these colors
that's beautiful no touch id
yeah i know i am a little salty about
that because you did it in the ipad air
like you could easily make this power
button touch id maybe not easily but
like you can do it i definitely would
have loved to have touch id over the
past couple of years especially when
wearing a mask was pretty much a daily
occurrence saying apple has faced lower
than expected development process on its
work to integrate touch id in the
phone's display we don't need it in the
display put on the power button i don't
care if it's in the display power button
iphone 14 to offer biggest camera
updates in years yes camera bump is here
to stay so these are all some prototypes
and it looks exactly like the iphone 13
it actually also looks like the iphone
12 so i don't even know so that my
friends is the iphone 14 rumor roundup
you guys heard it here first from mac
rumors and nine to five mac i'm
obviously very excited about the next
iphone i feel like a lot of tech
reviewers maybe myself included a lot of
my friends and people in the industry
we've become incredibly jaded because we
see so much tech so quickly and that is
not the case for an everyday consumer
most people do not upgrade their phones
every single year and i'm very grateful
that i'm able to do that i think we
sometimes take for granted the huge
upgrades that people are going from from
older devices a lot of these updates
yeah they are incremental and it's not
something that you need to have but what
i love seeing is people who have devices
who they haven't updated in five six
years get these new devices and it is
just so exciting to sort of see that joy
and see what a huge upgrade that is from
those older phones so that is something
that i'm looking forward to well thank
you guys so much for watching i am so
excited because it is tech season it is
iphone season so if you haven't already
subscribed please do so and hit the bell
so you'll be notified when i post new
videos i will of course have all sorts
of apple content but i also have a bunch
of other tech videos coming out so stay
tuned and look for those very very
shortly and if you'd like feel free to
leave a comment below as well and i
would love to hear from you what are you
most looking forward to in the iphone
14. i'll see you guys in my next video
bye
[Music]